thank performance in the other circuits
thanks to me
unfortunately stuck into micro trouble
then it's great city but I got a fever
since I came in slow reading the
temperature so if my brain is not
switched on how about at least in
advance okay so this is what
aphrodite PhD student number and - here
is my VIP I think it goes without saying
but please feel free to ask questions
during the talk if you don't understand
something that's probably my fault or
yours yeah observation in a very simple
scenario the simplest neural network I
can think of the feed-forward neural
network couple Himalayas sigmoid
abilities generic tasks so what I do is
I make a feature Network exactly the
same architecture as the students I
randomly clicks the way this is just so
I can have a kind of agnostic that's its
easiest one think of labels 32 generated
labels and it lists very similar happens
between this network size the student
while keeping the teacher constant in
the regime where we have noisy weight
updates so we're not just doing here
propagation with correcting up gradient
with some ways a big plus this two
magnitudes
so really the point of this is that
[Music]
there's a lower there's a lower bound
another degree of clusters and I'm in
I'm in years I'm so interested in them
great great under the context and the
brain isn't freeze but I don't really
care what the actual Buster's T
magnitude is what happens is as I get
iteratively larger networks
the steady-state error gets better and I
get faster land as you can see in the
legend so here is that here is some time
course everything then here's the
steady-state error recovery feast well
it's the strange well the teacher had
the same architecture as the smaller
student so it's technically the smaller
student could learn to 0 there is exist
some weight states of the smaller
student thank you perfectly
recreate the teacher so something is
going on here
and somehow the bigger networks are more
of us that they're kind of to the noise
in the weight updates why is this
interesting
well when I started my postdoc in
neuroscience the place those are people
here familiar with some degree in your
site sorry ok
ok basically a look at your sense what
happens is you make an animal like a
monkey or a mouse
/ - asked simultaneously image the
neurons and it turns out that you can
decode what the what their organism is
doing were like where it is in the maze
of spatial location display a
statistical regression on the neural
activities now the interesting thing
here is that you're imaging like 100
neurons are you you know you put your
microscope in somewhere random house of
millions so what that's saying is
there's a lot of redundancy in the
neural representation place else was a
particular example of that place cells
are cells which basically represents
location so if you put a mouse in the
may so any animal a place of fire where
one place L of Y when I'm at this place
in the maze of another place so if I
when I'm at this point to the base which
means that just by looking at the neural
activity I can infer where the mouse is
that was just an example okay but the
point is that you can actually decode
the location of a mouse in the base by
looking at a hundred random place cells
that were your microscope there's
million
whistles tens of millions so there's a
lot of redundancy like usually what they
use are generalized linear models I
think I actually know if that's you can
use the new regressions I've seen that's
who I'm in your version I'm essentially
foreplay cells in particular you kind of
have a bump function so literally like
this play cell fires with the highest
firing rate when I'm here and it's got a
Gaussian firing rate around here so it's
a bit lower here and it's pretty much
the early one here yeah but the point is
the fundamental point I wanted to make
this is a huge amount of apparent
redundancy in the brain and maybe
there's some other reason
from the observation I gave that needs
to be somehow deal better with noise
another interesting thing about this is
it saying that well networks in a sense
and normally we think about the reason
for that being the bigger networks type
rates and what'll complexity there's a
larger space of input-output mappings
that large in your network of rivers but
maybe there's something else going on
yeah well there has to be something else
going on here
because even the smallest network that I
chose could actually learn to zero error
in theory or there existed some ways
which that could happen okay so I'm
gonna think about all the things I'm
going to think about synaptic plasticity
in the brain which is the adaptive
mechanism over to the brain around at
least one of them a major one and I'm
going to just quickly go over all the
main things that happen in the brain
that meaning that inevitably you can't
have a very targeted way to update it
stick the brain that's going to be all
sorts of stuff corrupting yet which
means that learning is going to be very
noisy by definition in the brain and I'm
going to turn that into a new formula
that kind of doesn't impose a particular
learning but imposes
three proportions of good plasticity to
backgrounds that's the first part then
I'm going to look at how the bad bits
affect learning rate and I'm going to
show that that depends of the drama
create the error surface so I'm going to
build a geometrical concept which
essentially is going to tell us how much
weight changes in arbitrary directions
in a car learning and finally I'm going
to think about what happens when I
change network architecture if I have a
particular state of a neural network and
I transport it by a function to an
equivalent state over a different and
you're on that with a different
architecture they mandala properties the
the local geometry of the error surface
the loss function is going to change and
I'm going to check that actually that
change can essentially make make image
the new artwork in the image of this
mapping more robust to add plasticity
so essentially you can look at mapping
you can by changing network
architectures you can make neural
networks more robust to arbitrary
plasticity key and have faster learning
rates and great noise corrupted learning
regime I'm going to look at a general
online learning scenario this could be
in AI or neuroscience really at Berkeley
I've got a network with some weight w
depends on which changes over time
continuous language the network
performance on task but it doesn't look
perfectly sort of Samara there is and
somehow takes the way of learning right
I'm gonna try and keep the whole thing
agnostic to Apogee first of all there's
a huge body of literature trying to work
out what learning rules are used in
training but honestly we don't really
know yet with you know it's an unsolved
question good so just by definition what
is learning
well it's area of decreasing over time
right so if I take some time interval T
there are decreases which means that my
loss function
is it smoother but geometrically analogy
loss function is a lensing I can think
of so in this case I have two synaptic
weights obviously 30 millions in real
life and by the higher Emily's landscape
the worse my error what I'm trying to do
is go down hill yeah as long as I can
that's the geometric analogy so
obviously kind of obviously if I need to
get to the bottom which on average in my
direction of what change is going to and
just by the fundamental theorem is just
a mathematical representation of that
state the wreckage weight gained it's a
group underrated and I'm differently
with this gradient so group the
integrated it is negative and was points
inside my expectation so pressure
fireman's generic to learning weather or
climate what makes biological
variability part first of all suppose
I'm learning in a tensor or something a
very incomplete sensory feedback I don't
know I don't have enough information or
I did do even if even if I find the
exact direction and weights based
nutrition moves to optimally gain weight
their function
maybe I just did one tennis serve where
as I need to be looking at the whole
space of tennis service I didn't know I
have the fact sensory and then my
learning rule itself is perfect on some
systematic error it's not necessary that
I can implement perfect anagrams or
whatever in in the brain what does this
mean to you metrically well the actual
descent direction I'm going to tame it's
not going to curl it completely
accordion next on the side
Susan the brain actually intrinsically
unreliable their tiny collection of
machines in the subject to intellectual
annoyance they have for alien
collaborations once if the synapse is at
a particular strength
it doesn't necessarily stay there
through seconds actually there's other
stuff going on in the brain there's
various clusters T mechanism homeostatic
clusters T mechanisms learning other
tasks if you think of a particular task
in the brain we think of something
that's some vocal task it's not that
those sizes are only if you only utilize
to improve it that's us right stop going
on the brain so I'm playing a train
alone while I'm also going and then
there's time delays at every stage of
this feedback loop right large ungulates
detector and it's going to take time for
sensory information to be integrated
into particular plasticity mechanisms as
the system exits affected it's doing a
task I might be doing a task once in a
while then it might take time to do it -
maybe a different direction of move of
the arrow surface and I'm getting up so
there's all these issues that make
biological learning very perilous
now in order to in order to think about
this to represent this mathematically
whatever you want is to have some kind
of discrete representation for weight
updates but sigh haps is moving
continuously in time what I'm going to
do is I'm going to think about the time
interval that's smaller than the time
delay or the temporal sparsity of the
task between 0 and faculty I'm going to
say that no information on the task that
was after time zero is available so up
to time T ok and that there's always
going to be such as he just
yeah now that I'm going to try and do is
decompose this movement into a task
relevant proportion and it's us errantly
pushing and that's not a unique way to
do this I'm just going to do well but
what I'm going to say is I'm going to
define tasks
as any plasticity mechanism anything
that's moving their weight so there's in
a way that has no information of the
task suppose I give you a network with a
particular weight vector and they said
you're trying to let itself but I didn't
tell you what the task was choose the
weight update of course the weight
update is going to be nonsense because
you don't know phantasticus in
particular in expectation the way to
update you choose would be orthogonal to
the gradients so if I take a random
vector on average it's going to have
zero correlation because a disconnect
- Eddie I flip the same if I look at the
second derivative make grace I have a
second derivative matrix I'm going to
call it the Hessian further remainder
that's over that has eigenvectors and
because I had no information of the task
I'd imagined that my my wake up
endagered excellent to us is dinner
unbiased be projected onto the
eigenvectors
it's not like I'm going to
systematically biased myself towards a
large okay but yeah the next thing is
much greater than the clusters
that's that depends on the order of the
learning election the first I had a
personal learning rule they were
familiar with that terminology so one
where I not computing any information
sure I'm just meeting information with
Brady
so you could say a propagation that's
there there is a good example of a
person in that case faster and
elasticity I'm just trying to
approximate the great news so the touch
relevant process QP how much I projected
onto the gradient and in fact my total
of eight update would be some amount of
gradient plus this end which which has
the zero correlation system by the
second order one will be different
my optimal weights updates if I knew
exactly the gradient and MS you would be
minimizing but finding the optimal
direction given both the curvature and
the reading
okay so what Larry just to make them
that's easy for the rest of the talk I'm
going to assume that I'm only dealing
with worse little inning it's not the
[Music]
second do it over however do anything
else but it makes things cumbersome so
I'm gonna think about on this time
interval by weight updates doing
combination of gradients information and
this task here are the plasticity terms
okay so now I can go and make an
interpolated plasticity direction you
think of this as a kind of approximate
route so this is just yeah the the
average direction I'm going in over this
penguin and this is going to be
important for us little the right now
this is this song this integrated
Direction is a combination of parameters
and started appearing of the plasticity
and I'm going to break this Oscar and
the plasticity down further so first
let's think about how this testosterone
master teacher change as I change
increase the time interval what if my
doubled assignments were thinking about
them
well the extremal cases suppose this
task around the plasticity was arising
from something like a Brownian motion we
the undersigned
in that case the magnitudes of
sarsaparilla plasticity so how far it
me it's gonna scale with through time
what's the other extreme case suppose
it's taking me in a beeline in one
straight direction in that case it's
going to be linear exactly that would be
true if for instance I had a systematic
grading approximation area the solutions
of some area learning more likely it's
going to be so that somewhere in between
these two explosions teaster Harkins
great next what about haven't held in
scale with network size but again if I
had a Brownian motion of suppose it was
the same as the subject of is in fact
the case in then the total magnitude of
plasticity is going to scale with root n
where n is the number of sentences on
the other hand if it was a systematic
written approximation errors hey then it
would only scale with how much my
learning rate is essentially in the
direction the gradient so it could be
that I can only need update my weights
and with its 10% gradient and 90% noise
big that mentioned so noise is the sense
of how big creating this so these three
extreme cases but my overall expression
for the interpolated saying that take
updates as as a combination of these
extreme cases so I'm gonna be composed
as possible plasticity into two terms
this term is one that's linear inside
and doesn't scale so that would be as
for instance the systemic rate of
approximation error and the boat tone is
what you get if you have a cure for any
emotion on the spin axis so it's getting
routine and boutique remember that this
has this the left-hand side here is at
either denominator this one okay
basically suppose suppose my learning
rule is fundamentally
from in some sense rates so they can
only find the weight update which
correlates which has a given degree of
correlation of my gradient I can't make
it exactly the Greek let's say I can do
10% gradient and 90 percents nonsence
yeah if I increase the network size I'm
going to assume that that's the same I'm
assuming I have a learning rule which
where which is fidelity in approximating
the gradient is an end of a network size
that's what I'm going to do for us and
so actually if you look at some kinds of
learning with so some of the biological
only plausible for sending biologically
plausible learning rules that people
have been trying to construct in the
recent literature that's not actually
the case but what you can instead what
you can do in those cases is just as and
will even change as we update basically
and fitness can do to have some
independence of it a to basically yeah
so I'm assuming that there's this yeah
the dead of people learning also kind of
independent net websites but it's not
necessary for the rest of the matters
just because then you some I could I
could always change to change mean I
mean like it's always no no it could be
pointing in different directions breaks
all I'm saying is that on averages
uncourteous or gradients that there's a
portion of might not way to update that
is the gradient and this portion of my
way to update that's uncorrelated with
the gradient regulation is gonna be
square et and that's why I have this
this thing
yeah sure we're gonna have to be going
in the same direction I agree
over over this time interval T then this
is one slightly differently just
temporally correlated this is just this
is just just be one way yes in context
I'm thinking about this T is something
but smaller then the time delay is in
the feedback loop for learning this
feedback loop here so you're basically
what I'm trying to say lady barely on
this whole visible timers will from 0 to
capital T any information any any
synaptic massive system SST is not
influenced by information that there's
always going to be such a to you because
there are just inherently less okay cool
so I've made this kind of discrete
analog way of representing continuously
very nicely thank those good bits in
those back that's not going to see how
it's cut the bad bits effective learning
rate and it's going to be to do with the
geometry of the arrow service so think
about the local motor greater of the
stone visible we're going to represent
if I this case and of course this K will
change over at different time points
this is a local make time for any local
now I know that this the left hand side
has to be smaller than the right hand
side of my era has to be lower instead
which means that this K has to be
positive the more clusters with instant
more of learning if it's zero then there
was no them okay then all I'm going to
do is just the second-order Taylor
expansion okay and I get over the
equation that looks ugly but in
principle it's got a couple of
components first of all this is the
correlation of main ways
so this is the first determine the
Taylor expansion so if I was doing truly
closed a true backpropagation then this
would actually be the brilliant and it
would like no I'm not specifying what
the learning rate is this is true it
could be anything
oh sorry okay
you're thinking about learning right in
terms of how much I multiply the great
gameplay I'm not talking about learning
like that I'm talking about something
different very tough so what I'm talking
about when I say learning rates is how
fast I think is learning yeah I can't be
putting very fast even with small
weights updates are very slow with big
yes this is about how fast I'm learning
not about the magnitude of the weight
updates yeah yes sir there's a confusion
in terminology it's not what you call
learning greatest normally a panic okay
so this is this is the learning rate
equation which thing so I'm going to
learn faster if I have a vector X in
relation to gradients so if I can
exactly get the gradient it's going to
be better if I can exactly compute the
gradients and going exactly the opposite
pressure reading that's gonna be better
than if I can do half Brady apartment
lieutenant that first replaces its inner
product so this was my hints to say this
was my and this was this this is my
expression so I'm gonna look at learning
rates in turn over this momentum and
obviously if that if they interpolated
plasticity direction of employment or
correlates better with the greater net
Spencer and Biddle and faster and that's
this term so a better answer
correlations gradients based learning
if the gnome of my gradient slickly is
larger and I'm gonna learn to master
because you know you can ski faster on a
steep slope so if I have a very strong
gradient back and learn fast whereas if
I'm near a saddle point quickly I can
only learn slow and then I have a second
to determine which depends the Hessian
matrix this and I'm going to practice
but this is the curvature term this is
how much the inherent curvature of the
error surface changes we're learning
wrinkles mathematically this fit is
basically how much check eject on to the
Hessian matrix I'm going to which gives
me geometric intuition suppose I had a
completely linear error function locally
there was no curvature turn the Hessian
in Syria in that case this G would be
zero right because the house unicity
also if I good up if I think about only
velocity render pass this year I was
thinking about earlier it's going to
have no effect on expectation I can deal
with a huge amount of losses
well because I'm here I'm hearing it in
the linear Eric sir and I'm trying to go
downhill suppose I only go in iteration
it's very weakly far this doesn't matter
it's a little bit downhill
suppose I have lots of random movement
well it's equally likely to fill up the
Aero surfaces to go down near so
familiar so an expectation Costner and
little asterisk you would have no effect
or in the new rotor I can think about an
even better situation suppose my
services locally concave on a local
maximum in that case if I move in a
random direction things are going to
help me that's going to improve my
length level oh and you in any direction
of course this is not a really there's a
lot of realistic situations it's just
for geometric intuition more generically
to cover only the final de Janerio fund
the generic points in the generica
the concave or convex linear just
irrelevant process of moving the brand
new direction is gonna hurt me it
basically equates to if I move in a
random direction on average is that
going to be awkwardly corrupted Arnold
occurs the more quickly currents around
the directness the more
that character is going to hurt my
learning rate and the word down when he
curved in average Direction is the move
it's going to help other and in fact if
I just did aways updated it since Lucas
here it across here another class so I
literally did a brand new me something
how much that would change my own level
of training is going to be crucial to
the tracer that has seen over NS the
average eigen value professor because a
positive eigen value and as he responds
with awkwardly curve direction and
negative I can think response per
download the correct direction okay so
they have a lately we we just did this
Taylor expansion I'm going to substitute
my expression I had previously for pi
that make masticity of the time interval
they did in the first one so into this
loading we're in situation the personal
this bit is easy I know how much this is
going to correlate with my learning with
my it's the amount of gradient
information I have so how much how big
can this GE was what my don't be so the
second orders is remember there is high
return return they made no for now I'm
just looking at quadratic approximation
of the earth well G has to be energy the
smaller G is the faster alone and
fighting stops completely when G al
completes this is gamma 1 so that the
whole square bracket everything the
square American people superior so when
everything in the square brackets equal
to 0 is when this G which I'm going to
call them task difficulty is equal to
this equation here and thus water it is
the pups from hit alert of limits the
lesser curvature Harris back to them so
let's unpack this event so first of all
in the numerator we've got a gallon
water which means if I have more
movement in the direction of the
gradient the more gradient information I
have afraid it's a better area the more
bad curvature of concealment
what about the denominator well I put a
T here just saying of the logo I think
the longer it happens a weightless we
made updates the less curvature and deal
with because
that's where edges are moving then given
a small amount of curvature changes your
gradient direction of Locker enter and
then in these Nick brackets is just
basically the total magnitude of
elasticity I have unloaded if I'm doing
in Grandia if if I have some process
that's affecting a Brownian motion and I
have a lot of cyanosis
that's m3 tone then I might inevitably
handle of elasticity that egg hunt so
just to give you an idea I did some I
trained I think network for boys
lonesome and linear network so people on
the student teachers are so generic task
is they show you gradient so if the
network's training some level of error
and they in a steady state error unable
to graph this G so this is this local
task difficulty and these started like
lines signifying about 90 here so
basically at women initially local
testability is very low so essentially
it soars like so the average direction
they're going it's equally as likely to
help me astray
which makes sense right because I have a
completely untrained network and I
randomly but overlays
look I know an average changed my very
much the more I trained training the
more that's no longer the case until
Saskia Rendell plasticity hurts me so
much that it cancels up any effect I
have from having a good gradient
correlation and in the linear case 2,000
exact so I can take various the when how
much local particle to you can cook with
for instance Davis yeah the limine case
it's conservative in general and this is
something we found quite generically and
that's just because we have this already
terms in the Taylor expansion that we
have a good amount and the in general it
seems me very clearly seem to be bad for
learning
yeah this is just to give a bit of
insight though intuition is what's going
on so we keep training
[Music]
then you can deal with that so that the
only way to so as you see we have we
have a T in this denominator right and
the way just means a learning rate would
be equivalent to decreasing so it the
only way you can wait ugly that's what's
reflected here but in a ie could you can
I mean to prove convergence of any help
in the NGT to have weight updates whose
learning rates and that's the word
scales to zero right whereas in the
brain you have unavoidable and though
about elasticity magnitudes lapses move
but yes I agree that you can deal with
noisy weight updates by by changing how
fast you're moving in weight spaces here
no it's gonna it's gonna preserve the
amount of noise everything is going to
be smaller well okay so if we go back to
so if I changed my so the place I had
that was doing noisy grade gradient
approximation if I went to the scale how
much I was moving in each time step I
want to decrease again one but I'd also
have to decrease the amplitude so both
of these two terms will be multiplied by
constant
yeah three if something is what I'm
thinking of as Brownian motion that's -
that's something that's other way too
will vary from other things yeah you
kind of know some of there's some level
of Brownian motion in the sign up since
you can't get rid that's another way of
doing it acreage that's the equivalent
state but of course if we're looking at
a very very small time interval and the
Brownian motion is growing with routine
where it's the learning rate updates is
very cheap
though the relative proportions of those
two things is going to change as they
shrink down to get it anyway so they had
this formula will perform another
interesting yet which is generically
looking at decomposing velocities and
I'm gonna substitute it into this this
local toss difficulty to think that I
made up I'm gonna decompose local toss
difficulty in some class relevant
contribution and it's a security though
as I said before after in my class this
T so something which doesn't have
information on the Muslims is going to
project equally on average onto the
different eigen vectors of the Hessian
matrix for us because it's not
constructive perspective us they have no
information loss it can't last words to
dig a vector in a garage what that means
is that how much how much how much it
affects local festival is going to
depend on the trace of the history I
have a very highly positive trace as I
was saying earlier then the most
directions very awkwardly codes so my
fastest over so that plus the steers can
appropriate let me break the laws okay
because yeah I'm going to be deflected
upwards on the error landscape and then
those the contributions were class the
premises eternal so even if I was doing
here gradient suspended like that
propagation as you were saying I have to
scale my learning rate by when they
converge because as I get closer to a
local minimum or saddle points or
whatever the direction of steepest
descent is always going to also be in a
direction of nonzero curvature and as my
gradient becomes close to zero in
magnitude though approaches stationary
points my curvature doesn't do that so
in the end what happens is that the
positive learning benefit I get going
down the gradient is more than canceled
out by positive curvature by the fact
that for instance around the local
minimum
in a combat that made my arrow functions
locally convex which is why I had to
shrink my level rates as they bridge I
do question correctly that this term is
represented and it's basically how much
does the gradient is the normalized
radiant projected onto my own as the
hessian now i was i've been using a
first-order learning
I wanted to generalize this second-order
learning rules because that propagates
the equations this would be smaller
because in the end this thing you know
second-order learning like a degrade or
whatever what they do is they bias your
your direction of plasticity towards
flatter directions lots of directions
are good because the gradients stays
constant alone if I was using that
minimizing rule then this may be smaller
but I'm not okay now I'm going to get to
the core goals which is I think I think
this I've looked at the second-order
Taylor expansion how fast I'm running
and I've decompose that into the benefit
I get from going down the slope versus a
cost they have been active on average
directions are awkwardly coped and we're
training against say that if I randomly
preserve my weights my error goes up
then we'll train the and now I look at
and I realized all this to the local the
geometry of the Erika now what I'm going
to do is nothing look from a particular
Network and our network at an arbitrary
wave vector laboratory snakes I'm gonna
map it to a different your network and
that laughing is going to change the
geometry of the earth look and that's
going to change how much curvature I had
that ref direction and therefore will
change my learning rates and the point
is that's basically by adding redundancy
in the case under there are many other
architectural modifications very low
case I can increase my robustness to
tasks around the plasticity and by
manipulating with network architecture I
can end up with networks that could
learn to good steady state error even
in the presence of high amounts of noise
and lower bounds on the magnitude of
synaptic classes so okay I guess if it's
late which is how do i reengineering
item system very well despite and the
context of this talk one way of
approaching this reengineering the
system to have higher buses to toss
aggressive while maintaining sensitivity
to the spread of the quests okay so I'm
gonna have taken your network with the
state W I'm gonna make a family of
nothing spy in my particular case these
are going to be bad things that increase
the number of neurons it doesn't
necessarily have to be that but the key
thing about those mappings is going to
preserve them for alpha properties of
the network so I'm going to have a
bigger network that it saves exactly the
same as my original network at the state
w the ever existed FF that gained the
era of the this neural network in any
era no no no I'm gonna given values for
the gradients in the Hesse unity I can
just replicate the 305 using the chain
rule to see how the gradient and the
Hessian discotheque and from that I can
see how the local class difficulty that
thing that constructive changes and I
can affect minimize it in n number of
sentences because what I'm going to be
doing is looking at families mapping
internet websites for instance adding
neurons and I can find as an optimal
network science essentially in
particular cases though all the ones I
look at I think this could be a generic
analysis template for a very desirable
notifications I've just lived it to you
they're just so record
the the context Lorraine is weary with
making a generic kind of random tasks
let's see where there's a teacher which
has which has random fixed weights and
families of students the students have
to learn to be a teacher to recreant
properties of the teacher and the way
they do that is by supervised learning
week but then in both the teacher and
the student and then the teacher adverts
become the labels of the student and
then we do noise corruptive supervised
learning of the student and we have
gonna have family of students and just
like at the beginning of the talk the
key thing is that all of the students
and theoretically learned the teacher to
0 steady state error though yeah so
generally the teacher is going to have
the same athletic smaller student okay
I'm going to start the really simple
example just to give insight a linear
network so matrix so the output of my
student is quite improved my students as
you and I just put it through a major
push it through a metrics ability
there's an immediate problem here
because if I change the dimension of my
matrix W may change number of inputs
balanced which means I can't have a
fixed teacher but the way around that is
instead I just project the same teacher
about the same if I open that for high
dimensional space basically let you know
why sorry you either inputs and optimal
outlet directed by the teacher I get
some severe phobia of interest is the
envy basically goes from a smaller
dimensions will have connection and then
protect the inputs into the high
dimensions by the outlets it's a high
dimensions bioactive matrices DMT
essentially for my larger students
they're going to be in learning the same
in for health but mapping docks with
invertible transformation but embedded
in a higher dimension this so these
might be loaded in the is you and this Y
star you might need motivation is
pleased that this is still emotional
they're just low dimensional objects in
the hydrant it's the same task
why star is the optimal output forgiving
the teacher very development high
dimensional space a constant matrix D
[Music]
not the same models pretty question up
from you I just project that life star
you into a higher dimension in fact that
should not be Athena just viewing sorry
sir that's but that should be D advice
are you so this is an incredible
transformation if I know what the
India's then given these two guys I can
infer these and vice versa it's an
invertible transformation so it's the
same task just embedded in a higher
dimensional space I'm going to find C to
D one is the proportion by which I
increased my number of bits and C 2 is
complete in the proportion of a crystal
and they're going to be graceful and I'm
only going to be increasing networks and
the number of weights you expand the
network is going to be C 1 and C and now
I'm gonna given an arbitrary phase say
is the leader of the smallest I'm going
to project the state by a district
transformation fight in such a way that
the error of the larger students under
the image of the projection is the same
as the error of the original student
which activates W so it's going to be
this nothing you can see that because
because of these identities here
essentially if I multiply this projected
it by the petite that cancels out and
the same with the teeth the largest unit
network is going to have exactly the
same error as small as you
yes sir listen up do you do doesn't its
name
just Peterson but the rest of the time
yeah sorry I didn't have any sense yes
that shouldn't be I'm sorry I'm very
sorry so Shinde you here but basically
the BES said there should be a be here
as well because it's taking this earth
this input should be eaten so instead of
you here which means that I have a bt p
which is st you see that mean that there
yeah
okay now others my local who learning
rate how fast they're learning kenya
it's very forgiving proportions of task
relevant success iran or plasticity does
the smaller network alone master does
the larger Network own trusting well to
answer that question I'm just going to
basically put in my expression for in
selective synaptic classes which we did
at the forehead of which we thought in
the first class of into the second row
container extraction for how fast I'm
linked at the core the first the return
is just how much radiant I've gotten
laid in my weight updates and it remains
to see how this local touch difficulty
changes on the flight but because it's a
linear example I can calculate
everything analytically and I can say
that under the image of the
transformation the norm of the gradient
doesn't change whereas the trace the
trace increases by fantasy a number of
outfit ok
okay so the expected value of locals
arts difficulty it's going to be world
this is where we had before
staying this is exactly what we had and
we can push indeed we can put in these
some changes and see how how the
expected value properly changes and this
guy is going to get an extra CT so this
is basically how much so if you remember
this g1 how much curvature it was in the
direction of the gradient so if I'm
doing I'm going down vibrating how much
is the Heron curvature to Circus
lobectomy I'll point that's going to
increase biology because the trace will
so x factor C - I'm going up to the next
row C to here but then this n is the
number of waves and the new number of
waves is c1 times c2 blends in so this
decreases so we can see by the nick
colletti c1 and c2 we can actually
change how much we're changing the
output dimension so if I did great the
gradient was saying saying the same
statement magnitude whereas this was
increasing by a factor so you can see
plate over over this with respect back
to CT yeah I guess it's yeah nothing
much works out okay now what I want to
do is and with a minimize so just for a
quicker principle but infinitives I'm
going to fix the ratio
um there's no reason for this expect to
demonstrate it allows me to do some
numerical tests of my tamoxifen because
if I think c2 over c1 that now you have
three crabs there in this equation is c1
dependency to vice versa so now you can
minimize in situ or equivalently in c1
this expression and I'm going to say
that this is going to minimize the
steady-state error the network why
because suppose I'm in my original
network and I've learned into the weight
studies there thanks the error is when
any positive contribution coming from
the first one is canceled out by the
curvature but now play transports and
support the network to a bias in that
big pile in such a way that this G
decreases then suddenly this time the
smaller this red so I'm a spoiler which
means learning rate is again positive
for nekkid learn a bit more so I did
that minimization I just take you know D
by D c1 equals 0 or D by D any will see
her and take those stationary points
that I get to school networks ice one
assumption I have to make to get rid of
the main trace terms one which we need
very pleased seemed to be fine when we
today is that essentially the gradient
has projects evenly an average onto the
different eigen vectors of the hessian
which is this great thing which is
equivalent to this is this great
equation so i definitely young so if
you're one that gamma was the different
proportions of different clusters the
first term of gamma this email to task
for any mythbusters the second term of
gamma was the amount of system it's
systemic gradient approximation error
you could think of
yeah right and then your quick look at
the third term was demands of bracket
emotion and the analytic is this
analytic on
equation we got seems to perform what
the numerical simulated to the american
folks because the needs of plenty stay
[Music]
it's so it's going to point in the
direction of the positive curvature X
yeah but also okay well also when you're
in that situation you know that locally
around your minimum you're going to be
convex to every single directions
direction of positive curvature there is
no normal positive direction of
curvature near a local minimum but yeah
to give a bit more intuition and I first
of all in the linear case I think it's
reasonable and the reason I think it's
reasonable is because in the linear case
that has seen as constant whereas the
gradient is moving around all over the
place so the Hessian stays the same the
whole thing so in this case it's
reasonable I'll go to a nonlinear case
by actually I will agree with you it
might be less reasonable and the annuity
tested is numerically I had some kind of
okay I'll get to it later
but in the industry in this case
Vanessa's constant okay this is really
just a proof of principle to show you
that okay first of all what we're saying
is that by changing the network size we
can change the steady state error for a
given portions of class relevance faster
indirectly affecting that works ice
grief and I'm gonna get to that in
expect because yes it's a previous light
actually increasing see one since do
much better than increasing c2 because
he ones only in the Dominator and it's
only going to decrease this whereas c2
is
increase this yep cool but the only
reason they fix that was just to have
one free parameter in inaudible that's
only a greasy one Nelson that were size
unit and it's just a demonstration of
the mats but then that's checks out
nothing more than that but actually yes
you kind of preempted my next slide with
exceed we previously fix this ratio what
we have said is pixie - given the fact
that C to increasing see do seems to be
bad it well then the bigger we get the
better steady-state error we get and so
you have a line of work we're doing now
is thinking about there's just explained
in the architectural features in the
frame so I guess yeah so you guys don't
have necessarily over much do science
backgrounds but are you familiar with
the cerebellum the cerebellum has an
interesting architectural features so it
has this kind of surface and cerebral
this is the tiny bit of brain right here
it's not much it's almost look like your
brain if you look at an image
nevertheless that one kind of cell
within the cerebellum called the granule
cell which is just 70% of the neurons in
your brain it's good about 50 billion
granule cells and cerebellum and the
brain has about 85 urine and the
architecture is that a small number of
inputs of the cerebellum projections is
massive high dimensional space of
granular cells
so the granule cells are having a high
dimensional representation of a
fundamentally low dimensional input and
the weights of these large granule cells
are adapting due to basically you get an
error signal from something called the
muscle fiber sorry for planning like the
problem of paper which is very low
dimensional
okay sorry I think I didn't realize the
people about so much it's neuroscience
fear but basically the point is that we
know that this kind of learning systems
necessarily going to be very only give
you very bad approximation of gradients
that feedback is very low tonight so
maybe the reason we have all these like
billions and billions of granule cells
basically have a really high information
to allow us to actually learn bucks
like huge amounts of Pascarella plasters
plastic issues with great approximation
that's a bit of a tendon got something
yeah so yeah basically the cerebellum
don't really sure exactly everything
you have lots of interesting pathologies
when you have a bad cerebellum for
instance by trying to touch my nose but
I have damage terrible over here when
they have sued patients I did the
knee-jerk reflex if I have damaged
cerebellum jerking and going back to
patients inputs to the cerebellum come
from these small number from your own
school bus survivors and each mostly
fiber connects with billions of these
granule cells so there's a dense layer
of these 50 billion perennials over here
on your brain but because they're
getting inputs from a low dimensional
set of neurons and I'm assuming that
they're there what they're encoding is
quite low dimensional it's there that's
the only thing they gave what's wrong
and then they're also projecting outputs
on to something very low Tom it looks
like there's this massive dimensionality
inspection you could think of it as a
massive fitted layer with low
dimensional there is the biggest or a
doctor okay so London your exam
now I'm gonna look it's still at simple
neural networks people would neural
network that works with hidden layers
and sigmoidal linearity just for sake of
an example I like in the linear case I
can increase the size of network without
changing the limit of its network so I
can have a fixed teacher I don't have to
do all that stuff for projecting
teachers my Nadi is essentially just
gonna act ghost neurons neurons
connected by cosine axis I'm going to
connect
I'm going to add neurons but then
upgrade their person
taking activity in series they did
actually attack yeah never but of course
this is like a turbulent he waits by
which the you neuron is connected then
yelling at us yeah but all the way it's
a non zero yeah sure I just chose one
where they were Syria it doesn't matter
basically any language resources okay so
that's there's not issues competitive
than your example first we'll be fine
analytical expected for the mid-year
sample but we're gonna be able to buy
Buster but another limitation is in the
linear case there was always an
invertible mapping between smaller and
larger networks they're always
equivalents they typically with Aris
nonlinear case what's actually going to
happen is the larger neural networks can
fix a bit a fundamentally wider range of
behaviors there's going to be behaviors
module here and network Pompey
replicated by by X cool in your number
my analysis is going to be looking at
waste and the image of something the
mapping from the small of your network
so in that sense I'm looking at a
restrictive set of weights I'm going to
talk about your publications that later
okay so
I'm going to make an arbitrary weight
vector they near on that were extinct
them and as I said my transformation is
gone just add zero weight so it's going
to add in your own fingers silences and
that if I think about a representation
of this mapping it's either going to
send if I take the weight here it's
gonna basically be the identity
transformation on the existing weeks
this can be a 1 or it's gonna add a big
zero
so if I picture this is a matrix if I
picture this Math League matrix the
matrix is going to be like that that's
super cool here is that so it's gonna be
it's gonna be a semi orthogonal make
gonna satisfy this property and now
whatever my Ponyville is whenever the
states from there is gonna be just by
the chain rule I get these identities
though is basically so basically a
transpose times the numerator is equal
to Co brilliant understand any transpose
hey it's the altar that should be Obama
has he answered there should be a to
that supposed to change and now you're
something I'm gonna make this verse
because it a is fixed because it has
nothing to do with the weights they know
is on its going to have nothing to do in
average with the gradient direction or
the Hessian direction so basically the
gradients is going to project unbiased
here to the different eigen vectors of a
and similarly so basically the the
gradient is go so the gradient is not
going to be biased towards regular I
think this is reasonable base fixed
whereas W could be anything that's has
to be anything if that's true then
essentially one enter this projection
some of the sudden some of the basically
I can think about how much is take a
normal DC this has
one eigen values and has some zero key
values but the norm of this is going to
depend on how many zero and so I get
these approximations that say that the
gradient is going to expand by abuse
ratio which have increased the number of
ways and the trace is going to increase
the nearly with a number of ways but if
that assumption is true then these are
exact but of course it's not going to be
exactly true because it's always going
to be fluctuations like there's going to
be a slightly higher projection to one
night in vector so given these I can now
substitute these things into the local
to us difficulty packet so this is so I
have my X and my new expression for
local ties difficulty it's now it has a
function of the old components of the
the local test difficulty of the
untransformed mapping I'm going to be
adding these extra terms so as I get
again I'm going to make the same
assumption that given questions earlier
and in this case I actually agree that
it's a less valid assumption so it's the
assumption that I get the the gradient
projects unbiased be an average onto the
eigenvectors assume I did but I have a
lonely thing in the supplementary
information paper giving a bit more in
seconds away
it's but it's it's a heuristic the nice
the lucky thing is that even if it's not
very true it doesn't in the end effects
Piazza networks eyes cuddly we also did
some other simulations of a very
asymmetric task that's vacation task and
checked it out and it seems to be fine
but of course I can I'm never going to
say that in a carousel never always
going to be that may not be always be
true it just seems to be true that's
that and even if it's not true it
doesn't in the end-effector of all that
work size calculation but anyway under
this assumption we get a formula frogs
on that website again and actually what
I forgot to do last time I think my
doing this time is I'm making this so if
you remember
the amount of movement to the direction
of Radiance gamma2 represented a
systematic gradient approximation
narrator due to VGA the fact that I can
only copulate to some fixed degree with
the gradient because they have to stay
like that learning and gamma 3 was like
the amount of Brownian motion it said
someday sources of synaptic plasticity
that increase with networks that's so of
course if I had large amounts of sign of
transfer and that's the increase of
networks fat is like a thick network and
have some for any emotion and that's
going to utilize excessively large
networks now you can see this is ever
three-straight donate on the other hand
in the back boots I'm flattening out the
Arizona's actually as I get bigger means
that if I have a face proportion of if I
have some faster other plasticity turns
in that are fixed in relation to our
gradient information I have something
like 10% gradient is that nice large
networks repetitively back to Harrison
if I have a bigger time delay same
difference
bigger networks do better with the
bigger time delay because they have
flatterers though the gradient changes
lesser remove it's identical
an engineer is the size of the teacher
network I have to pick a teacher I need
it's like you know a proximal network
space and stars the network sites oh
well I could have I could have
rearranging it to the end scenarios you
basically oh the facts I have I can show
you to reread it's just a neater
equation and then I did some numerical
simulations again like I did in the last
case so again this is what is but in
general I think I was looking at smooth
and easy neural networks like tiny
compared to the ones you official
intelligence applications and I think in
general if I looked as though that I
lives have really large 1x or whatever
basically those you make that work I
think in general these with
underestimates and there
is a limitation a duty to the beginning
which is the fact that I'm only looking
at Network states of the transform
Network the image of states of the
original network if I add a lot of
layers to my network maybe that opens up
whole new areas of weights lists which
are not isomorphic which I can transform
back to smaller Network and maybe those
who have very little to us difficulty
maybe I opened up new really nice flat
sections with this but that's an
advantage of lower large of your
networks that kind of attribute to the
larger range of invalid behaviors that
they can and are well known like fudging
your works have larger sets good
it means the best one is better this one
this is purely due to the local geometry
of the air service laughing out so
really it's not like I fighting these
particular n stars of any real
importance they're just making sure the
Maps checks out but really that the
point I want to make here is this
transforming transforming neural network
architectures make you more robust
Petoskey rather classes and that could
be in an artificial intelligence
applications use of other things like I
don't know like having a stochastic
gradient of course or just having bad
noisy labels or certain nosy inputs or
labels that kind of stuff different
computational neural network have
different reversal toss rather
plasticity and that depends into local
geography network that's really the
fundamental message you want to give
here and that pretty much concludes the
through everything
[Applause]
[Music]